[Musique]
bonjour à tous pourquoi chercher plus
loin sur France 3 le meilleur de nos
rencontres nous fait mener la vie de
château aujourd'hui et ce n'est pas de
tout repos avec au programme château
château fort et fort tout simplement
nous allons rencontrer des héritiers qui
doivent entretenir leur patrimoine des
bâtisseurs qui vont construire un
château fort médiéval et puis nous
évoquerons la réhabilitation des
forteresses militaires abandonnées vivre
dans un château un rêve en tout cas dans
les dessins animés de notre enfance la
réalité au quotidien et tout autre je
vous propose de partir pour la sonéloire
au château d'zenet il est situé au cœur
du village Janine d'zenet la
propriétaire et a vécu son enfance avant
de partir ailleurs elle y est finalement
revenue parmi ses préoccupations
l'entretien et surtout arrivver à
financer la rénovation des
[Musique]
toitures c'est notre maison d'enfance
donc on la connaît on y est habitué sauf
quand on est enfant ça paraî
j'osais pas ouvrir les portes des des
parties plus éloigné du château où nous
habitions pas parce que j'avais
l'impression que j'allais trouver des
ancêtres et je faisais toujours ce rêve
un peu récurrent d'ouvrir une porte il y
avait des ancêtres et derrière encore et
encore et
[Musique]
encore c'est dans la famille depuis
tellement longtemps ENF qu'on on est
quelque part avec ça on le porte c'est à
la fois un devoir de transmission que
l'on a reçu et qu'on doit transmettre il
y a la magie du dieeu il y a la beauté
du lieu qui donne envie de pas le
laisser se
dégrader le château d'osenet est une
bâtise médiévale dont la construction a
débuté au 13e siècle agrandi au fil du
temps son toit est constitué de lave à
la place des tuiles des pierres plates
en calcaire recouvrent et protègent le
château un vrai trésor architectural
rare et précieux classé et protégé par
les Monuments Historiques mais qui est
menacé aujourd'hui par les effets
dévastateurs du temps
aujourd'hui le château d'Osny est en
danger il y a des problèmes de toiture
très importants
et tant sur les dépendances que sur la
partie
habitation donc notre
génération rite de ce poids de toutes
les les toitures à à
refaire à haosn localité située à 10 km
de tour nu le château qui date du 15e
siècle menaca ruine 9 ans de travaux
coûteux dans les années 70 le père de
Janine le marquis d'osen avait pourtant
pensé sauver ce toit précieux en
rénovant entièrement les
laves hélas malgré tous ses efforts
aujourd'hi le problème est resté entier
car les réparations n'ont pas tenu
toutes leurs promesses les pierres
utilisées n'avaient pas les qualités
pour résister au gel alors qu'un toit en
lave est parti pour durer un siècle
celle du château n'en ont pas tenu la
moitié
aujourd'hui s'écroule et le toit de la
partie principale donne des signes de
faiblesse c'est à la génération suivante
celle de Janine de trouver des solutions
avec jers un ami l'état des lieux
s'annonce aujourd'hui difficile problème
oui
[Musique]
regarde dit que il y en avait il y a 7
ans il m'avait dit il y en a pour une
petite dizaine d'années ça et
effectivement là on y est et quand il
pleut là tous ces trous tout partout où
on voit la lumière là et ben il pleut il
y a des taches d'eau sur le sol on ça
commence par une petite fite puis de
plus en plus importante
ça conruction dans l'autre grenier ça il
y a une poutre maîtresse c'est juste
auudessus d'une poutre maîtresse il y a
vraiment une fite important
h ici ici ouais euh c'est vrai et la
charpente
[Musique]
souffre c'est des travaux
énormes très importants très
lourd excessivement cher ça atteint des
millions d'euros c'est c'est c'est
énorme et nous les avons pas nous avons
hérité du château mais on hérite pas
forcément d'une fortune qui va
avec Janine d'zenet n'a peut-être pas de
fortune mais elle veut sauver son
château comme début de solution elle a
décidé d'ouvrir des chambres d'aute son
idée trouver de nouvelles sources de
financement tout en offrant un peu
d'histoire dans un cadre hors du commun
ses chambres sont prêtes et son activité
démarre tout
juste pour l'instant ce sont surtout les
amis qui passent à osenet le portail
n'est jamais fermé et on a toujours beau
beaucoup aimé
recevoir et même si ses frères sont loin
elle est toujours prête à faire table
ouverte avec sa mère qui habite une des
ailes du château il n'y a qu'un pas à
faire pour se retrouver tous
ensemble
ah tarte tte mais
mercig on se laisse faire hein
j'ai j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour
vraiment beaucoup parce
que son travail les chambres d'utes je
lui dis souvent que ces château est un
Angre
magnifique c'est c'est c'est c'est une
espèce de d'orre qui prend on est àé par
lui qui nous
absorbe tous les gens qui viennent ici
ils se plaisent beaucoup hein même les G
qui viennent à la chambre d' mais
j'espère qu'il va pas me dévorer que je
vais pouvoir me remettre à c'est l'
magnifique le Fame
a la devise de la famille ici k cru
j'espère qu'on pourra dire dans quelques
temps dans quelques années et bien oui
il fallait y croire c'est ce que je fais
j'y
[Musique]
crois la vie de château c'est un vrai
défi pour des particuliers propriétaires
c'est un autre défi pour vous François
Xavier verger vous qui êtes
administrateur de ce château de buser à
butin puisque le château appartient à
tout le monde c'est le château pour tous
ici ce monument appartient effectivement
au ministère de la Culture qui l'a
confié au Centre des monuments nationaux
pour le faire vivre pour le faire aimer
pour le faire partager effectivement de
ce fait c'est le Chau de tout le monde
avec quel type d'activité pour attirer
une clientèle des visiteurs des
touristes de tous âges et de tout pays
des activités pour les enfants des
activités dans le parc dans le potager
qui a été reconstruit récemment des
activités pour expliquer ses peintures
les portraits ou les représentations de
châteaux comme c'est le cas dans cette
pièce vous parlez de ces châteaux
représentés sur ces tableaux on les doit
au au compte de bussir àbutin Roger de
busir àbutin c'est lui qui a longtemps
vécu ici un personnage un peu à part à
la cour de Louis XIV qui ne s'est pas
fait que des amâes il faut le dire c'est
un homme de guerre qui a connu des
campagnes victorieuses et c'est un homme
de lettre également c'était le cousin de
Madame de sévignier qui a écrit un
certain nombre de lettres magnifiques
mais aussi des récits sulfureux qui lui
ont valu la disgrâce et donc l'exil ici
par le roi Louis XIV il décrivait de
façon un peu trop précise la vie à la
cour qui soit libertin était un fait
mais il a aussi décrit la vie des autres
libertins et ça était moins apprécié
bien sûr ça na pas plus forcément nous
allons prendre notre direction Lyon la
Puiset pour un vrai défi technique
reconstruire un château médiéval à
l'identique 300000 personnes se pressent
dans ce château qui n'est pas terminé
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que les
visiteurs il viennent nous sommes donc à
Guedelon en dans Lyonne là où il y a du
bois là où il y a de la forêt le défi a
pu être relevé et 70 personnes y
travaillent au quotidien dans 11 corps
de métier le tout chapaé par un chef de
chantier très efficace vous allez le
voir notre machine à remonté le temps
nous mène en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1230 tu te rappelles que elle sera
évidée là au milieu hein mais je me
demande si je dev pas le faire avant
deer les boudin alors ce qui est pas
évident dans la construction d'un
château fort du 13e siècle c'est que il
y a pas de mode d'emploi il y a pas de
manuel donc il a fallu euh réinventer
retrouver ben comment est-ce qu'on
transforme des rochers en en pierre pour
construire ça personne nous l'a dit donc
il a fallu essayer euh avec des outils
alors on a on a quand même on s'est
documenté on se doutait qu'ils allaient
effectivement utiliser des coins des
coins métalliques pour casser les
rochers on a essayé et peu à peu ce qui
a marché on l'a gardé ce qui a pas
marché on l'a écarté et c'est devenu une
méthode et la méthode en la reproduisant
c'est devenu une technique et
aujourd'hui un carrier peut foisonner
donc produire à peu près 1 m cube de
roche par jour car alors comment ça se
passe ça va on va essayer de prendre la
pierre en deux là utilisant le le fil
qui se voit assez bien d'accord donc ah
bah là il y a pas de souci hein euh donc
c'est une pierre en la coupant en deux
ouais B on va avoir toute façon les les
lits sont pas bien réguliers donc non
mais enfin là donc c'est voilà ça va
être deux belles boutises hein des
pierres plus profondes qu'on mettra dans
le mur et euh ouais tu as le donc l'idée
c'est que ça force sur cette partie là
du coin h que ça touche pas le bout pour
pas qu'il rebondisse que ça touche pas
la tête pour pas que ça délite la pierre
h et de la pierre avec deux emboutures
donc deux trous
[Musique]
pour pour construire leur château il
leur faudra extraire 10000 m CUB de
pierres de cette
carrière guaydelon c'est un peu
l'écoonstruction avant l'heure toutes
les ressources à proximité sont utilisé
la pierre pour les murs la terre pour
les tuiles le bois pour les poutres et
les échafaudages les pigments pour les
teintures et puis parfois ici entre les
pierres de Grais de la carrière
surgissent des petits gisements d'ocre
aggloméré alors tu as trouvé ouais ça y
est regarde récupéré ça
[Musique]
wouh quelques grammes suffisantensite
pour décliner ses couleurs du jaune du
rouge de l'orange
elle domine les peintures murales des
premières salles du château elle donne à
gueddelon cette ambiance si
[Musique]
particulière les guon on transforme
finalement un écosystème o où on voit
les arbres les rochers comme
potentiellement des maisons ouou des
monuments à à construire et ce qui est
très important c'est c'est de pouvoir
communiquer ça effectivement aux
visiteurs on est bien dans le 21e siècle
dans cette société où finalement il faut
faire des choix et c'est important de
garder ces gestes là qui ont été les
gestes de construction de nos arrièr
arrière grand parents ils sont pas si
loin comme au 13e siècle les dessins
préparatifs se font à l'échelle 1 sur le
sol même de la loge il faut souvent
vérifier ajuster trouver des solutions
sans s'éloigner des intentions
originelles ces crayonnages servent à
fabriquer des modèles qu'on appelle des
ponfs ils reproduisent la forme exae
thorieut all j fait tiens en théorie il
y a une petitte VO une arête à s petit
derrière mais ça va êt
Infern aussitôt dessiné ces pensifs vont
servir de guide au tailleurs de pierre
au Moyen-âge les tailleurs étaient
considérés comme les aristocrates du
chantier mais aujourd'hui à gudelon
cette hiérarchie n'a plus lieu d'être
tous les bâtisseurs sont
égau
pour peu qu'il a envie d'apprendre
chacun est les bienvenu sur le chantier
c'est le cas de Tony
Vignolo à l'origine j'ai une formation
de conseiller juridique j'ai travaillé
plusieurs années comme juriste pour une
association j'étais venu ici il y a 3
ans çaéta un petit peu un coup de foudre
et ça a fait partie des choses qui m'ont
décidé à faire une formation de tailleur
de pierre et à l'issu de ma formation
j'ai pu trouver un poste sur le
châteauah c'est c'est vra que Ch a
tendance à devenir une grande famille
parce que si on est 70 salariés euh on
travaille 6 jours par semaine on mange
ensemble le midi voire même le soir on
peut passer nos journées de libre aussi
ensemble ça crée un lien
particulier bonjour Vincent salut Tony
quelques outils usés ah ouais moi
gradine cassé je réparer quelquesuns là
ouais te poses ça là ouais
ouais je te on prends quelques broches
le principe de base c'est qu'on bosse
tous ensemble s'il y a pas de tailleur
de pierre ou ou de maçon il y a pas de
forgeron et s'il y a pas de forgeron il
y a pas de charpentier il y a pas de
Boucheron donc voilà c'est un ensemble
si on enlève un des métiers le château
ne se fait
[Musique]
pas château Renaissance où nous sommes
ici en Côte d'Or à busir à butin avec
des touristes de passage originaire du
Canada mais installé en France chez nous
et ici en Bourgogne pour visiter ces
châteaux c'est quoi pour vous la vie de
château est ce que ça fait en vie ah
c'est le romantisme c'est c'est
l'histoire c'est les richesses de de la
France parce que ça ça se voit nulle
part et et bien sûr les les Français ont
ont préservé ça c'est un trésor c'est le
meilleur trésor de la France tout ça et
vous en voyez beaucoup des châteaux vous
avez sonné tout toute la France presque
toute la France surtout à véo et et en
combie aussi etou depuis beaucoup
d'années je je rêve de vivre en France
de depuis l'âge de 10 ans donc
maintenant on vit notre rêve et la
Bourgogne ça ça fait partie du rêve du
rêve de notre rêve oui bien sûr bon
retour dans le sud et revenez nous voir
bientôt en Bourgogne merci j'espère avec
nous on va poursuivre la visite avec les
forteresses militaires de frongchecé
avec l'exemple de la citadelle de son
fortifié par Voban né en Bourgogne
l'ingénieur militaire de Louis XIV en a
construit une trentaine en 40 ans et en
a réhabilité 130 partout en France on
disait ceci ville assiégée par Van ville
prise ville fortifiée par V ban ville
imprenable et bien la Citadelle de
Besançon a connu les deux sorts elle a
coûté si cher d'ailleurs que le roi
aurait dit ce serait demandé si elle a
pas été construite en or retrouvons
l'une des guides de cette citadelle avec
l'un des chefs de chantier chargé de la
restaurer annlor Charles et guide
conférenciel avec son ami Séverin le
chef de chantier elle arpente le
vertigineux rempard ouest en appelant du
dou al remarqu-tu comme Monsieur Vaan
était pragmatique pour sa façon de
s'adapter au rocher au relief de la
pierre là ça se voit bien ou les
remparts de la place forte épousent les
formes de la colline notre colline qui
fait 120 m de haut c'est quand même
vertigineux
effectivement
la citadelle a été opérationnelle au
début du 18e siècle la place forte sert
à protéger les frontières à dissuader
l'ennemi d'attaquer à loger des troupes
B était plus un homme de dissuasion
qu'un guerrier c'est un homme de guerre
mais qui fait tout pour empêcher les
guerres son côté humain peut se lire à
travers les matériaux utilisés là tout
au long de notre chemin de ronde un
bourlet de brique nous suit la brique
n'éclate pas comme la pierre le calcaire
de de notre colline que tu connais bien
ce calcar est très dangereux puisque
l'artillerie tire des boulets
métalliques la brique sera nettement
moins dangereuse pour les
[Musique]
troupes la sueur épargne le sang disait
l'architecte du roi à Besançon vauon
conçoit son système de défense en
édifiant côté ville deux lignes de front
la première le front Saint-Étienne est
protégé par un bastion avancé appelé
demi-lune un fossé et un pont Levie un
grand espace de près de 300 m sépare
cette ligne du deuxème front le front
Royal cet espace appelé GLA oblige
l'ennemi à progresser à
découvert dans le souci de préserver ses
hommes il creuse un souterrain sous ce
[Musique]
glacci nous retrouvons anlor à l'entrée
du tunnel appelé communication 110 la
galerie relie les de de front et permet
en cas d'attaque une circulation et un
repli optimal des soldats en les
protégeant du feu
ennemi à la fin du 17e siècle la
citadelle compte une garnison d'environ
400 hommes l'espérance de vie moyenne
n'est que de 30 ans pour un soldat de
Louis
XIV c'est à la sortie du front Royal que
nous retrouvons Séverin et annelor
Séverin fréquente la citadelle depuis sa
tendre enfant
et après avoir uvré à la restauration
des Salines d'Arc et ceant il s'ffire
désormais à rendre son lustre
fortification de besonan la rénovation
du bastion sur lequel il travaille avec
son équipe prendra près d'un an et demi
la citadelle de vaauan a été construite
sur une colline de pierres ce sont ces
mêmes pierres qui ont servi à la
construction du chantier oui donc en
majeure partie les pierres sont dans
quel état 3 siècles
après la pierre tout ce qui est vraiment
à l'eau exposé au vent était très
endommagé très endommagé Jive on a
remplacé 80 % sur certaines faces et les
faces qui sont abritées on est passé à
30 % donc là c'est la première étape
quand vous restaurez un ouvrage c'est
déjà un état des lieux on fait un relevé
à l'identique des pierres de de
construction toutes les mêmes côtes les
mêmes dimensions elles sont posées
exactement au même endroit qu'elles
étaient il y a 3 siècles là c'est la
partie làdessus donc c'était un peu
altéré donc nous avons créé une poutre
en béton qu'on av retaillé faceon rocher
donc c'est ce niveau qu'on voit là voilà
voilà et nous avons mis toutes les
pierres nœu et nous avons conservé
quelques pierres anciennes avec les
marques de bossage des tailleurs de
pierre descendu de son Épron rocheux
nous retrouvons anneelore sur les rives
du Doux elle embarque à bord de la
navette leevauan pour une promenade
bucolique en compagnie de Nadine la
capitaine bienvenue à bord
merci mesdames messieurs bonjour et
bienvenue à bord du vauan alors à partir
d'ici vous avez un très joli point de
vue sur la Citadelle de Besançon qui
domine l'eau là-haut de plus de 100 m
ces falaises citadelle esttendue sur une
superficie de 11 haectares et que je
vous invite à visiter sans plus
tarder c'est le côté agréable dans notre
promenade c'est que les gens ont
vraiment un point de vue original qu'
n'ont pas quand ils sont là-haut en haut
il voient toute la ville là du bateau et
ben on voit ça cette face là après quand
on fait l'autre tour on passe de l'autre
côtéation la rive gauche et la rive
droite aussi puisque vauan fortifié les
les 195 hectares de la ville ouais et
puis ce qu'on essaie de faire partager
un petit peu aux gens qui viennent vers
nous c'est que déjà van ben on le trouve
partout en France quel que soit presque
l'endroit si vous faites les côtes
françaises vous avez des œuvres de Van
soit des travaux partant de zéro soit
des des fortifications de certaines
viille donc un peu partout en France il
y a v ban et puis moi ce que j'aimais
bien c'était le côté humain de cet
Hommel enfin on parle toujours des
fortifications donc c'est un côté très
très solide la pierre he bien sûr mais
mais mais l'homme est intéressant je
trouve aussi par que c'est ces voyages
il est allé partout et aujourd'hui c'est
facile de faire des kilomètres toute
l'année à son époque TR oui il faisait
énormément des milliers de kilomètres
tous les ans pour aller d'un point à un
autre donc c'est un homme qui était sur
les routes qui était au contact des gens
et qui s'est pas contenté d'être un
courtisan Louis XIV moi j'avais bien
aimé ce côtél
[Musique]
quoi l'effort militaire avec deux
époques différentes 1670 la citadelle
mais de siècles plus tard fin 19e le
système défensif serré de rivière du nom
du général à l'origine de ces
constructions bien connues par les
sportifs participant au trail d'ff mais
tout au long de l'année l'association
avalfort s'occupe de valoriser ce
patrimoine son président c'est un ancien
militaire nous l'avons suivi lors de sa
visite au fort de Fontain au sud de
Besançon une autre façon de vivre la vie
de château avec son propriétaire et avec
une vue imprenable
[Musique]
bonjour André comment va bonjour Pascal
ça va bien et toi ou oui ben écoute ton
fort s'il a pas subi les affres des
combats il est quand même un peu en
quenouille avec la nature qui reprend
ses droits et qui nous fait tout
écrouler hein 60 ans d'abandon tu as
repris ça il y a 6 ans tu un sacré
boulot et puis on sait pas comment faire
hein
là moins d'aligner l'argent il y a pas
de solution je me suis concentré sur le
haut si tu veux tu vas voir les travaux
qu'on a fait c'est pas mal ah bah c'est
parfait très bien
[Musique]
impeccable le fort n'étant pas inscrit
au répertoire des monuments historiques
André et son épouse Marianne l'ont tout
simplement acheté en 2009 pour y
construire une maison
d'ôte une façon originale de valoriser
un patrimoine gravement menacé alors
qu'est-ce que tu en dit oh là là tu as
fait fort là dis non al je suis surpris
hein je suis
scotché il faut regarder par ici pour se
retrouver dans un fort parce que sinon
on est ailleurs hein ouais enfin si tu
veux on a on a retapé la vieille maison
qui est là pour faire des gites de
manière à accueillir des gens soit
intéressés par leseffce soit par soit
par le site lui-même dans la mesure où
Fontain est situé à égale distance de
besonçon qui est une ville intéressante
de d'Ornan et Dark estn donc pe quand
même loger une famille de H personnes et
une famille de quatre personnes moi je
me fais pas trop de souc sur la
commercialisation c'est très réussi
vraiment allez viens on va à la maison
déguster le vin du
jur madame madame est làc
plis les heureux propriétaires habitent
à de pas depuis leur terrasse une vue
spectaculaire ouvre sur tout le
[Musique]
Jura élaboré un petit document sur le
fort de Fontain pour les visiteurs alors
ça leur permet de voir tu vois combien
ça a évolué dans le temps ah on est
passé là tout à l'heure et vous êtes
passé là tout à l'heure avec magnifique
ouii c'était quand même très très
important
effectivement alors on leur donnera et
de de bien comprendre oui puis repartent
avec ils en parleront chez eux
exactement mais vous vous rendez compte
de la chance que vous avez d'habiter ici
habiter un fort oui ENF d'habiter ici
c'est une chance extraordinaire c'est un
peu excitant d'être d'êre propriétaire
de
pierre de
casmat spectaculaire malgré tout donc
effectivement puis si tu veux regarde la
vue comment veux-tu qu'on
soit on avait pas placé les canons
n'importe où et les for étaient
effectivement là c'est nous qui on a
tout le jur là ah oui c'est
formidable et N et puis plaisir merci
encore en tout
cas plus facile que de trouver son
chemin dans ce labyrinthe du château de
Busira butin faites un tour sur notre
site internet pourquoich chercher
plusoin.fr vous y trouverez en
intégralité nos visites des châteaux de
sonéloire de celui de Guedelon en
construction ou des forteresses de
Besançon partagez vos coup de cœur avec
nous pourquoi chercher plus loin et nous
on cherche la
[Musique]
sortie
la semaine prochaine dans